RIGHT WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
VETERAN AFFAIRS COMMITTEE TO
START I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF. THAT HAVE MADE IT
POSSIBLE TO FOR US TO RETURN TO
THE CAPITAL HAND TO OUR ABILITY
TO MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARTICIPATION IN OUR HEARINGS.
TO THAT END I WILL NOW SHARE A
FEW NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS
OF OUR HEARING A REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF
EVERYBODY HERE TODAY. AND
ENSURE THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO
DISCUSSION. DUE TO THE CURRENT
STAY AT HOME ORDER WE ARE
DISSING PHYSICAL DISTANCE HERE
OKAY HEARING ROOM AND RATHER
CAPITOL BUILDING SORT ONLY ABLE
WATCH AND PART TWO OKAY. IT THE
YEAR FIRST. NOT FOR WITNESS
TEST TODAY. OF TODAY'S. IN THE
ROOM HERE WERE HAVING-
PHYSICALLY DISTANCE A
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE ELEVEN MEMBERS
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF DISTANCING.
ALL THERE ARE ALSO STRICT
DISTANCING AT PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENTAT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
I WILL ASK YOU APPROACH
MICROPHONE. I WOULD ASK THAT
THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARING ROOM ONCE YOUR DONE
TESTIFYING OR RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT PLEASE BE SURE. TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DEPENDING UPON.
LEAVING THE CAPITOL INCLUDING
LIMITING ELEVATOR USED TO ONE
PERSON AT A TIME. FOR A DIAL IN
WITNESSES. WE ARE GOING TO BE
USING A MODERATED. TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE. THREE ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO
OH TWO. YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS
NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY VETERAN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING PLEASED. TO DO
SO. AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. IF YOU'RE
CALLING AND PLEASE ELIMINATE
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
PODCAST AND YOUR SMART DEVICES
TO REDUCE SOUND DISTORTION YOU
CAN ALSO CALL THE COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
THREE FIVE FIVE WELL IF. YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
RATED PHONE US AND WILL BE
THERE TO. I ALSO WANT TO NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE POSITION
LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK YOU
FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTAIN
SERVE THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
WHILE BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS THAT WE ALL FACE. SO
WHY DON'T WE START WITH ROLL
CALL. WILL. HERE VOEPEL.
BOERNER HORVATH BROKE. DALY
FRAZIER GLORIA MATHIS YOUR
MURATSUCHI PETRIE-NORRIS. SALAS.
FOR ALL RIGHT AND WE HAVE-
THREE BILLS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO
AYE THE MOTION. RIGHT OF LET'S
GO AHEAD AND DO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. IRWIN YES
WHEN I AND VOEPEL. THE BELT
FIVE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I BROKE BRO I
DALY. DALY I FRAZIER FRAZIER HI
GLORIA. GLORIA I MATHIS MATHIS
I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I
PETRIE-NORRIS. PETRIE-NORRIS I
SALAS. SALAS AYE ALRIGHT AND MR
VOEPEL WHY DON'T WE- HAVE YOU
STARTED. ON YOUR WAY UP- WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE A AB EIGHT
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE ALLEN
MISTER VOEPEL WILL BE DOING THE
PRESENTATION WELCOME MR VOEPEL.
SACRAMENTO I. FEEL LIKE A PILOT
WITH ITS AUCTION MASCO NEW. SO
AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE SIMPLY
ASKS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
TO CONDUCT A STUDY TO ATTEMPT
TO DETERMINE WHY FEMALE
VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE AT SUCH
AN EXPONENTIALLY HIGH RATE
COMPARED TO THEIR MALE
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM FOR FEET
VETERANS. ONCE THEY GET OUT OF
THE MILITARY MORE WOMEN ARE
SERVING IN THE UNITED STATES
MILITARY. TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
TO HAVE A 15% INCREASE TO- TO
WEAR OVER 20% OF MILITARY
MEMBERS ARE WOMEN. WOMEN ARE
ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
VETERANS GROUPS. NOW HERE'S
SOME STATISTICS THAT WE NEED TO
BEAR OUT. AND THIS IS MORE THAN
JUST GUESS WORK. WOMEN VETERANS
ARE AT A HIGHER RISK OF
COMMITTING SUICIDE COMPARED TO
NON VETERAN WOMEN OVER THE LAST
TEN YEARS WOMEN NON VETERAN
WOMEN SUICIDE RATE IS GOING UP
85% THAT'S TRACK. FOR VETERAN
WOMEN IT'S GONE UP TWO HUNDRED
AND 50% NOW WE CAN ONLY GUESS
WHY. I BELIEVE THIS IS JUST A
PERSONAL OPINION HAVING SPENT
NINE YEARS IN THE MILITARY
SEXUAL HARASSMENT OUT NOT RAPE
DENIAL BY A COMMAND FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT MANY TIMES IN THE
MILITARY AND. ASSEMBLYMAN
MATHIS WILL BEAR THIS OUT MANY
TIMES IN THE MILITARY YOU HAVE
TO WORK FOR SOMEONE THAT HATES
YOU. THEN YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
AND MANY WOMEN REACT TO THAT
ALL OF THEM DIFFERENTLY
EVERYONE'S AN INDIVIDUAL ON
THAT ONE. BUT I WOULD GUESS FOR
WOMEN THAT'S INCREDIBLY
DRAMATIC- IT'S THIS WOMEN IN
THE MILITARY HAVE A MUCH
TOUGHER THAN MANY PEOPLE AND
I'M NOT JUST- PICKIN ON MEN
MANY MEN FAIL IN THE MILITARY
AND HAVE TO BE JUST CHARGE WITH
THE GENERAL DOES CHARGE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T HACK IT SO THAT PART
OF SUICIDE. WE NEED TO DISCUSS
AND PREVENT. MILITARY VETERAN
SUICIDE IS VITALLY NEEDED-
WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING FOR A STUDY
TO BE DONE. IN THIS STUDY CAN
BE THE BEGINNING OF WHAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CAN DO IN
ORDER TO GIVE BACK TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SELFLESSLY
PUT THEIR LIVES IN DANGER
THROUGH THEIR SERVICE TO OUR
NATION. THE FEDERAL VA HAS
CONDUCTED VERY LIMITED STUDIES-
IN MY OPINION ONCE AGAIN THIS
IS A PERSONAL OPINION THE VA
PRETTY MUCH FAILS THAT QUITE A
BIT OF VETERANS HEALTH CARE AND
FOR WOMEN. THEY THEY ARE
HORRIBLE THEY THEY JUST DON'T
PERFORM AND I'VE ALWAYS HAD A
BITTERNESS THAT GETS TO BE A
THEIR- IN OUR OWN CALIFORNIA
VETERANS RESOURCE BOOK. PAGE
NINETY EIGHT THERE'S THREE AND
A HALF PAGES ON SUICIDE NOT A
MENTION OF WOMEN NOT TO MENTION
THAT IS SIMPLY KEEP IT GENERIC
VETERANS SO. THE END OF THIS
STUDY IT WOULD BE NICE TO GET A
HALF A PAGE. DETAIL A KNOCKOUT
WOMEN VETERANS SUICIDE. MADAM
CHAIR A COLLEAGUES. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
MISTER VOEPEL IS THERE ANY
OTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. WE
HAVE ANYBODY ON THE CALL.
NOBODY ON THE LATEST GERMAN ON
THE PHONE LINES IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT SUPPORT ONLY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. INE FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR COMMENT. AND FOURTEEN
PLEASE CHECK YOUR LINE FOR ME
TO. PERSON PRESIDENT
UNRESPONSIVE REMOVING FROM THE
QUEUE NO FURTHER IN Q. PORT.
ALL RIGHT HAVE SOMEBODY ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OKAY IS THERE
AN- OF PLEASE WELL ON BEHALF OF
THE TICKET BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER DOWN. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT IS THERE ANY TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. WHO. ALL RIGHT
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE IT ANY
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER GLORIA. IT'S WORKS WITH
MY APPRECIATION TO THE UTHOR
OF A FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD COULD BE APPLIED TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR IF YOU'D
HAVE ME- AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU TESTIMONY SPECULATE ON THE
OUTCOMES I RECOGNIZE THIS BILL
WOULD ACTUALLY PROVIDE SOME
DEFINITION IN SOME REAL TRUTH
BEHIND. WHAT WE THINK IS GOING
ON AND WHEN ACTUALLY HAVING TO
BE WHAT WE KNOW- I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS BOARD OF
DELIGHT SUPPORTED TODAY- AND
HAPPY TO BEFORE HEARING CENTER
RIGHT KIM MISS MATHIS. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. OF MISTRAL
FELL I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
ESPECIALLY AS A FELLOW VETERAN
MOVING THIS FORWARD OR WOMAN
VETERANS AS YOU STATED GO
THROUGH SOME EXTRAORDINARY
DIFFICULT TIMES BOTH IN AND OUT
OF MILITARY SERVICE- I THINK
THIS STUDIES FOR PAST DUE-
ESPECIALLY DURING THESE TIMES
OF A COVERT AS WERE ALL HERE
MASSED OF. YOU KNOW THE STATE
ORDER HAS A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
WITH I TIME AND WITH THINGS
LIKE SUICIDE I DON'T MIND LEAD
TO MUCH MORE PROBLEMS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH PTSD- SO
I THINK IT'S DEFINITELY VITAL
WE GET THIS THROUGH AND GET THE
STUDY DON AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS I'D
LIKE TO BE ADDED AS A JOINT
AUTHORED ON YOUR BILL AND TO MY
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ON. I WOULD THAT'S A YUBA CO
AUTHOR A JOINT AUTHORED THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS. MISTER
VOEPEL I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ON GOING ADVOCACY FOR
CALIFORNIA'S VETERANS AND
ESPECIALLY FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WITHIN VETERANS AND ALSO FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO ALWAYS CALL
IT LIKE YOU SEE AT I TOO WOULD
BE HONORED TO BE ADDED AS A AS
A JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS BY.
THANKS FOR BRINGING UP FOR. SO
WHAT. OR YOU KNOW YEAH ACTUALLY
YEAH. OKAY IRAQI. WHO ARE THE.
IF YOU. ALL RIGHT I'M THE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALRIGHT WE HAD A MOTION
BY. OKAY AND ALL RIGHT. SO
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL CALL STIR
SECRETARY MOTION IS THE BEST
APPROPRIATIONS IRWIN HI- WHEN I
WILL TELL RIGHT THE BELL AYE
BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH MY BRO BRO ON
MY DAILY. DALY AYE FRAZIER.
FRAZIER II GLORIA. GLORIA I
MATHIS MATHIS I MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I SALAS SALAS I
LIVE IN THERE. ARE RIGHT WELL I
APPRECIATE EVERYBODY COMING ON
TIME AND- I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING FORWARD
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL AND-
THAT WE'RE NOT MISSING ANY
MEMBERS ARE WE- ALRIGHT. THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED.